hey youtubers is charlie thank you
everyone that submitted questions for
this week's Walking Dead Q&A just in
general it felt like there were a lot of
questions about Daryl being gay being
not gay so I definitely added that to
the list of questions that I pulled
usually based on the big WTF moments in
an episode I can tell like what people
are going to be talking about after the
fact but sometimes I'm a little
surprised by questions that people have
usually the end up being for really
funny things so I just look forward to
digging through your guys comments I
also wanted to say a huge thank you to
everyone for 600 k well you know
whenever I started making videos I never
thought my channel would get this big
hopefully in like another five years
YouTube won't have burnt to the ground
we're still talking about Walker's
dragons and comic books so from the
bottom of my heart you know ass in
serious thank you to everyone you guys
are awesome so let's answer some
questions careful for spoilers from the
episode if you haven't seen it yet go
for cookie time first question Finley
kreygas the w in the a what do they mean
Walker and Alexandrian so yeah Sam
stamping Rick's hand with the a that was
a little weird the W just means the
wolves that's what I think if you
remember at the last community the one
where Tyrese died it's that wolves are
near I think that's what the W is it's
just the mark they leave the scavengers
and yes I do think that the wolves those
people are the scavengers from the
comics the AI think just represents
Alexandria the stamp of the a the reason
Rick chuckled whenever he looked at it
and saw that it was an a was because he
was remembering the hunters whenever
Gareth marked it on the church it was to
remind the survivors that they had been
stuck in train car a so he wanted to
make them feel trapped like they were
trapped in the first episode again it's
nice to know that Rick can chuckle about
that given everything that's happened
since then so next question Rachel k gas
why do Rick and the others want to take
down Alexandria instead of integrating
with them also are we to assume that
Jesse's husband is abusive that's what
it feels like well to answer the Jesse
question first so in the clip for the
next episode we see him being like day
drunk talking to Rick so he just seems
like he's off the rails in general
alexandra breckenridge was on talking
dead though she did say at one point
their marriage was good but since the
apocalypse things haven't been very good
between them I am betting that they'll
show us some actual physical abuse
though it just feels like that would
contribute to this like slow build-up of
tension until it explodes in the finale
to answer your question about taking
over Alexandria it's mostly because they
feel like the people in Alexandria
aren't strong enough to survive in Rick
thinks if they take over or you know
maybe Carol to that they'll be able to
protect everyone better I think they're
definitely happy with alexandria that
like the way that the walls are really
strong it's a 45 community but I think
they don't want to leave their survival
up to the decisions of other people like
if she goes down with this wolves group
like if they end up being the next big
villain they don't want another repeat
of the run-ins with the governor that
would be crazy if we had the same type
of finale moment you know we're like the
governor came up with a big group of
people in his tank of the gates of
Alexandria next question Chloe asks how
do you think that Morgan will make his
appearance and when so there's a couple
possibilities I think he could be found
whenever darrell's out ranging around
for people to induct into the community
whenever he's looking for new recruits
or he could show up in like some big
final conflict actually just add a third
option he could be walking around with
those scavengers that would be a big WTF
like if you see this evil group and then
surprise surprise Morgan is sitting in
the background I don't think that Morgan
would be leading them though he seems to
antisocial for something like that
although Scott Gimple did say that he
had been socialized just a little bit
since the last time we saw him in season
three but he saw Abraham's map to
Washington DC's so even if he didn't go
to Alexandria he is somewhere in that
area because Alexander is like right
next to DC next question spotto asks who
did Sasha see at the start of the
episode I assume you're talking about
you know whenever she sat down and she
was like come and get me she didn't see
anyone specifically if you're talking
about the pictures though like she was
just seeing random people that used to
own those homes I did see a lot of
comments about people wondering why
Sasha shot all those pictures up I think
they just drove her crazy like maybe
they reminded her of life before the
apocalypse or of her family that she's
lost shooting them up maybe you know as
like a way to shatter the illusion I
definitely think she expects something
really terrible to happen that's why she
went so crazy about the watchtower she's
like I know something's gonna come
there's no way it's going to be this
nice the whole time next question
generico asks do you think that the
Alexandrians know everyone is infected
oh you're talking about like the virus
so yeah on talking dead Aaron said that
because he'd have worked in and around
DC he and Eric his boy
and Eric probably had a pretty good idea
of it but I think there are apply some
Alexandrians that have no idea don't
forget that most of the people that live
there right now moved in right after the
apocalypse started so a lot of them have
no idea how bad things are they just
know it's bad I think that's part of
what's driving the survivors crazy like
especially Sasha when she freaked out at
the party but she's like don't you
realize what's going on out there
they're way worse things to be afraid of
next question demon born asks do you
think that Rick will tell deanna about
the bat [ __ ] crazy places they've been
like terminus in Woodbury I don't think
they'll explicitly say well we went here
and this happened and then we went here
and this happen like he's not gonna
write the book of their life but he did
say we've had to do things to survive so
I think Deanna has a pretty good idea
that they've done some awful stuff don't
forget she's a politician and she won
reelection so she is a genius at reading
people so I think she understood what
Rick meant when he said we've done
things that could change though
depending on who survives to season six
and if they're still in the safe zone at
the beginning of season six I mean I
think they will be I'm really hoping
alexandra breckenridge is character
survives like Rick would probably
eventually tell her about those places
next question filmic Phil asks do you
think that the season finale is going to
be a no way out type of thing okay so
for people that haven't read the comics
that's a comic book storyline so I won't
explain it in great detail but i will
say that yes i think what's going to
happen is is they'll take that storyline
and use it to bridge the end of the
season and the beginning of next season
next question lemonade asks do you think
that jesse is going to be in a
relationship with rick at some point
well I don't know about relationship
like you know long-term relationship
depending on how long she survives I
definitely think they'll be having sex
though alexandra breckenridge said this
really funny thing she said when Rick
went to kiss her when they were filming
that scene Andrew Lincoln freaked out a
little bit because his character has not
had thoughts like that like really
sexual thoughts since the beginning of
the apocalypse like if you rewind back
to season one when he found his family
again when he reunited with Lori and
Carl I think he was just happy to be
with them he wasn't thinking oh great
here's someone that I get to have sex
with again that's just not what drives
his character he's been all about
survival but now that things have calmed
down a little bit I think he's
entertaining that idea and it's freaking
him out a little bit and freaking out
Andrew Lincoln is an actor next question
Jake are
is there actually any relationship like
sexual relationship between Aaron and
Daryl no I I don't think that there's
anything going on there I think that
daryl is just warming up to the idea of
new friends I'm sure tumblr fan fiction
has its own ideas about what was going
on subtextual e with all their scenes
but i think that Daryl slowly starting
to trust him we'll see where that goes I
don't know a whole lot about Eric we
haven't seen a lot of Eric but Aaron
seems like he knows his [ __ ] so it's
totally possible that they could keep
Erin on for season 6 and kill Eric in
the finale I do definitely think some of
those new characters are gonna die in
the finale but in terms of Darrell being
gay I don't think that they're going
anywhere with that they're not going to
say like absolutely yes or absolutely no
it's like the RIC thing having sex is
like the last thing on Darryl's mind
I'll be real interested to see if he
meets anyone that makes him change that
makes him reconsider that but I think
that after Merle died and then after
Beth died just a bunch of pieces of him
totally died so he's kind of empty right
now I do think that Aaron is going to
help fill a motorcycle shaped hole in
Daryl's heart seriously Darrow got
really happy when he saw that motorcycle
I think for him that represents
something that he knows he can control
and it represents a certain level of
freedom thank you so much everyone for
so many questions these are always a ton
of fun to do remember there's only three
episodes left 14 15 and 16 so I'll try
to do something a little bit special for
the finale but if there's any specific
bonus videos you guys want me to do be
sure to leave a request and
congratulations to this week's giveaway
winner let's see Naruto Uzumaki I think
you're in Japan so it'll probably be
paypal instead of the Amazon gift card
so be sure to message me on the back end
my channel so I get your contact info
new round of the giveaway whenever I
post my next Walking Dead video once we
get to the finale I might explain some
of the comic book arcs that we've
already made it through for those that
are reading the comics were around life
among them no way out that that's kind
of like the territory we're in oh and I
almost forgot they actually confirmed
some stuff about the spinoff so there's
going to be six episodes in season one
which I know sounds weird battle
premiere at the end of the summer what
will probably happen is is they'll use
that to lead into season six so they'll
air all those episodes and then like
after the the spin-off finale they'll
tear the first episode of season six
they picked it up for two seasons though
so there's a guarantee and second season
they didn't announce how many episodes
are in that second season though I
they just want to test it out to see if
people like it and if it tanks then
they'll just do like another six
episodes and and call it a day that's
actually good question let me know what
do you guys think about this spinoff
what do you think about the idea of them
airing it at the end of the summer and
using it as a lead-in for season six
would you rather them air episodes like
right alongside season six episodes in
related news while you guys wait for my
next bonus video you can click here in
case you haven't seen my Carol's cookies
video I totally love making that
thumbnail that was so much fun and you
can click here for my breakdown of the
game of thrones trailer that just posted
totally awesome way better than the
first trailer thank you so much everyone
for watching and thank you again for 600
k now let's all do the thing six hundred
thousand times